hi it's Matthew Martin from details and
we just finished with the giorgio armani
show the show is elegant and beautiful
with a lot of military undertones there
was a bunch of great military cut
jackets that were cropped at the waist
there were very cool double-breasted
suits that were actually printed even
though from afar they looked like they
might be fabric they were amazing way to
add texture and has a very cool trompe
l'oeil effect which I thought was
interesting all the boots in the show
were really shiny and military which
were great some of them were leather on
the bottom and canvas on the top the
pants in the show were a lot were velvet
which added a really nice drape one of
the main themes in pants at Armani was
pleased there were pleats all over the
place a lot of guys are afraid to wear
pleated trousers they feel like it gives
you more about not so flattering
silhouette but the actually the opposite
is true if you wear them with a really
fitted jacket or a tailored blazer a
pleated trousers is a really elegant way
to mix up your wardrobe please follow me
on twitter at details mat and for more
videos from shows check out details on
Oh